skiers and snowboarders are headed up to
Lee Canyon for a late season snowstorm
that promises some really excellent
conditions well into the spring
meteorologist Jerry Brown spent the day
at Lee Canyon and spoke to winter sports
enthusiasts right in their element
despite the calendar we have mid-winter
skiing conditions here and just
beautiful but the real problem for
skiers and borders may be getting up and
down the mountain we definitely want
everyone to check and prepare so check
envyroads.com call 511 they will have
the information on Spring Mountain Roads
up here and if there's any winter
restrictions storms like this in early
March are what keeps us going for the
rest of the season usually so up to two
feet this Saturday another foot possibly
next week so if it stays like this like
it's going to be a really beautiful next
couple weeks where all is said and done
with this storm as you can imagine
skiers and borders are in a very
positive state of mind how are the
conditions clinicians are awesome right
now I'm in the snow we got over the last
two days have been great so conditions
right now are definitely at Peak we
haven't had a season like this in quite
some time what's it like up there tell
me about it John it's getting crazy out
there the snow is coming down on like no
other it feels like Utah snow but it's
not you just feel like you're in heaven
if you have what it takes and that would
be change or four-wheel drive with snow
tires a veritable Winter Wonderland
awaits you up here in the spring
mountains Jerry Brown reporting from Lee
Canyon for eight news now